in this video today we are going to make
a list and this this will be the top 10
of the best finishing moves seen in the
movies of the monsterverse if you
disagree then put it down in the
comments section and if you agree then
you can click that like button for
support and also remember to click the
subscribe button to be a part of our
mind cue family so let's get down to
business
number 10 godzilla kills the male muto
tail swipe
[Music]
number nine mothra stabs rodan the heart
attack
[Music]
number eight godzilla defeats com the
cardiac arrest
[Music]
number seven monster zero defeats rodan
anti-gravity
[Music]
number six godzilla kills monster zero
nuclear annihilation
[Music]
number five kong kills the warbat cobra
kill
[Music]
number four gong kills the skull trawler
deep throw
[Music]
number three mechagodzilla kills the
skull crawler the power slicer
number two gone kills make a godzilla
head hunt
and number one godzilla kills the muted
female the kiss of death
and so with that we come to the end of
the video do leave a like for support
subscribe to be a part of our minecraft
family and also click that bell button
for regular updates on new monster
content right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam